[Musique]
monsieur vous quitter paris ça fait
longtemps que vous venez à paris deux
ans à paris depuis quinze jours
seulement et vous retournez nous venons
de passer trois semaines à 7 dans le
midi et vous venez en france et à paris
depuis quand il ya trente ans et que
nous prenait sans ma femme et moi que le
connaissons paris et qu'est ce que vous
aimez paris nous avons bien la façon de
2 vers la nourriture
enfin la défense est ce que le petit vin
rouge à huit dans un temps ses meilleurs
culte et ça n'est pas un fait l'accueil
des parisiens on en est très gentil nous
avons trouvé tout le monde est gentil
mais j'ai l'impression que les français
sont morts rue specter qu'avant la
guerre à bord et ils se sont assagis
nous oui il me semble
[Musique]
mademoiselle vous quitter paris
vous êtes pressé combien de temps à
paris
[Musique]
et vous allez-vous maintenant
qu'est ce que vous aimez à paris
c'est mon souhait
l'apathie maurice
et j'aime site
hier dont 10,6
vous avez bien les parisiens oui ils
vous ont bien accueilli
comme chez nous ils sont plus
qu'inquiets vous oui je retourne à liège
de mal je bossais hot boys
j'aime beaucoup paris je connais très
bien paris je n'aspire qu'à y retourner
le public pc et qu'est ce que vous
préférez à paris
j'aime beaucoup paris j'aime bien tous
les parisiens aussi mais beaucoup cet
anglais et après dix jours à paris vous
angleterre keystone pensée paris ce
n'étaient que trois jours mais paris
nous l'aimons beaucoup et il aurait aimé
et nous avons vu toutes les choses
habituelles comme ça que coeur et l'arc
de triomphe et nous et oui c'est une
ville qui vous plaît oui très bien
j'étais déjà une fois ici mais c'est de
ma deuxième fois et j'en ai vu beaucoup
plus cette fois que la dernière fois je
crois le modèle vous êtes suédois je
vais repartir en suède
évidemment du parfum
côté vins et du champagne qu'est ce que
vous pensez de paris je trouve cette
très belle très joli très gai j'aime le
comprendre
on viendrait à paris oui je vais
mir le printemps prochain
en fait les études je crois
[Musique]
ça rapporte un métier hop ça dépend des
jours combien peu près on peut faire
environ 100 francs vous êtes canadien
oui et vous êtes depuis longtemps paris
ça va faire violence du jour 6 jours
et qu'est ce que vous aimez appareils le
gens sont sympathiques
ce joli médias la police la police
gasquet nous fait la police bon vent +
ans quand on joue dans la rue n'est pas
le relever dans la rue non c'est
interdit est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de revenir quand même à
paris monsieur de texas oui elle san
antonio et vous avez paris oui j'ai
visité par et qu'est-ce que vous avez
visité paris à c'est une formidable
émission être les donc 24
[Musique]